(relaxing music)
- [Voiceover] In the middle
of the harsh desert in Peru,
surrounded by miles of rolling sand dunes,
there's a small oasis
that's far from a mirage.
The town of Huacachina has a
population of about 100 people
and is one of the few
remaining natural oases
in North and South America.
It's a popular tourist destination,
hosting tens of thousands
of tourists each year.
In its heyday, the village flourished
as an elite resort
getaway for the wealthy,
who once flocked to the
waters of the lagoon
because it was thought to
have medicinal properties.
The resort became so popular,
it is even featured on
Peru's official currency.
Legend holds that the lagoon was created
when a beautiful native
princess was apprehended
at her bath by a young hunter.
She fled, leaving the pool of
water she had been bathing in
to become the lagoon.
And the woman, herself,
is rumored to still live
in the oasis as a mermaid.
(relaxing music)